era muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 nos acompaña en esta
oportunidad
flavia pro font y ya es politóloga y
también activista ambiental es
cofundadora del movimiento extinción
rebelión en argentina
autora del libro extinción la
supervivencia de la humanidad un juego
que estás haciendo para evitar el
colapso un libro que estamos viendo su
portada en imagen es un libro además que
nos revela con evidencia científica la
crisis ecológica y climática que
atraviesa nuestro planeta y también los
niveles a los que ha llegado según las
palabras de su propia autora la voy a
citar como civilización estamos
transitando un momento histórico que
debemos comprender y este libro por
supuesto es una gran ayuda para eso
aunque hay mucho daño que ya es
irreversible flavia propone muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
flavia en tu libro hablas del estado del
planeta en cierta clave de alerta verdad
estamos habitando un mundo que va camino
a la extinción que implica esto
por un poco el clivaje radical que tiene
el libro algunos se han dicho que es más
un manifiesto que un libro que está
catalogado como en la sección de
ecología o de ciencia tiene que ver con
empezar a hablar con la verdad creemos
nosotros no hace demasiados años 26 por
lo pronto que el panel
intergubernamental de cambio climático
se reúne todos los años advirtiendo cada
vez con mayor radicalidad desde la
ciencia empírica que ya no tenemos
tiempo para revertir algunos de los
aspectos que la acumulación de gases de
efecto invernadero en la atmósfera va a
provocar indefectiblemente no entonces a
mí me gusta o siento que con
responsabilidad en este tiempo ya
tenemos que empezar a hablar no
solamente de evitar la crisis climática
algo que ya es imposible imposible sino
aprender a tomar medidas para qué
comunitariamente aprendamos a colapsar
mejor decimos algunas no el ipc se nos
dice que tenemos siete años para llevar
nuestras emisiones de dióxido de carbono
globales a la mitad 30 parques de la
corona neutralidad no hay ninguna
política pública que esté apuntando
hacia esa meta y hablar de ciclos de
inflexión ya nivel y così sistémico es
la única manera de referirnos a la
realidad geofísica de lo que está
sucediendo como si fuera verdad no como
si fuera real
en este sentido exponemos que estamos en
una ruta rumbo a la extinción de no
hacer un cambio radical y profundo en
nuestra matriz de producción y consumo
precisamente hacia allí apunta mi
próxima pregunta flavia porque el modelo
de producción el modelo de consumo
capitalista que sostiene no a este
modelo de estar en la base de la crisis
y son incompatibles con el cuidado del
medio ambiente desafiar a ese modelo de
producción y de consumo es entonces la
clave para digamos
de refundar la realidad la salida deberá
ser revolucionaria desobediente
a esta altura del partido yo tengo ya
unos unos cuantos años en diferentes
espacios de activismo desde hace 20 que
he trabajado dentro de instituciones
dentro de grandes planes que es dentro
del estado también creyendo que estén
jugando con las reglas del sistema
podríamos llegar a transformar con
profundidad lo que necesita ser
transformado no porque no hay ningún
tipo de posibilidad de que simplemente
con arreglos de geoingeniería o con
bonos de carbono podamos evitar los
peores efectos de la crisis climática si
yo creo que sin un levantamiento
disruptivo social masivo global y
simultáneo no vamos a poder llevar a que
se tomen las decisiones con la
radicalidad que necesitan tomarse y
cuando me pregunta si es la matriz de
producción y consumo lo que tiene que
cambiar yo creo que si sabemos todos
es así ahora para que eso cambie lo que
tiene que transformarse necesariamente
es el paradigma de percepción la
cosmogonía la episteme en cómo
concebimos las relaciones de nuestra
especie con el resto de las formas de
vida en el planeta y desde ese lugar no
va a ser suficiente con que las
condiciones materiales cambien para
refundar algo nuevo si no transitamos
también una transformación de la
percepción del pensamiento de cómo
concebimos nuestra historia en el
planeta si las seguimos consiguiendo en
forma lineal queriendo crecer y que
acumula riqueza en forma infinita o si
nos entendemos parte de un sistema vivo
y ahí ya nos metemos en cuestiones
bastante más complejas en paradigmas y
en cambios culturales
hablando bueno de paradigmas de cambios
culturales flavia este modelo no solo es
capitalista también es patriarcal y el
activismo implica entonces
necesariamente cierta lucha contra esa
opresión y esa violencia verdad
patriarcal en ese sentido hay una
articulación que necesaria casi natural
no entre la lucha medioambiental y el
movimiento feminista y cómo se da esa
articulación
y totalmente yo creo que sobre todo en
los países de esta región de américa
latina que han liderado algunas de las
luchas feministas anclas en territorio
quizás más relevantes del mundo en
argentina particularmente la
conversación que amplió el feminismo
entendiendo al patriarcado no como una
lucha entre mujeres o disidencias y
varones sino en un sistema de opresión
específico que tiene registros
históricos específicos en donde en el
proceso de transición hacia el
capitalismo que se dio a fines del siglo
15 principios del siglo 16 pero
ciertamente un esquema en donde la
homogeneidad del pensamiento patriarcal
de
una cosa por sobre y con poder de las
demás en el proceso sobre todo en casa
de brujas de euro en europa y de
colonización en américa latina y en
áfrica se instaló como sistema no el
patriarcado entendido como sistema de
opresión no como una lucha coyuntural de
mujeres ganando más derechos sino como
un paradigma civilizatorio que reforzó
el cientificismo lo lineal el
mecanicismo y que ahora necesariamente
tiene que cambiar con lo cual si las
luchas feministas hoy están
perfeccionando muy fuerte con los
movimientos ecologistas y ambientalistas
históricos en esto que es la madre de
todas las luchas si se puede decir que
hay algo muy interesante que planteadas
en tu libro extinción hablas del
concepto de distopía en esta época en la
que todo está cambiando podrías
desarrollar esta idea para nuestra
audiencia para todos nosotros
cuando estaba escribiendo extinción de
hecho lo termine de escribir al libro en
los primeros meses de la pandemia del
aislamiento social obligatorio y ahí
tuve que reversionar un poco incluso
cómo estaban conformados los capítulos
porque aquello que quizás yo planteaba
en una charla te di en en 2019 o que
ocupaban las primeras páginas del libro
que iba a suceder a futuro nuevas
enfermedades que nos atacan nuevas
pandemias empezó a suceder entonces lo
que yo veo y siento que hoy estamos
normalizando de forma muy peligrosa es
la distopía ocurriendo no una distopía
entendida como un riesgo a futuro
terrible sino como de a poco y eso es
una habilidad muy marcada de nuestra
especie podemos también acostumbrarnos a
una realidad distópica en donde es
normal no poder tocarnos entre nosotros
no poder hablar nos cerca no poder
compartir espacios
y eso desde la ciencia ficción siempre
ponga es el área distópico y hoy es la
realidad que habitamos y no estamos
haciendo la suficiente fuerza creo yo
social para entender cómo es que hemos
llegado aquí y hoy cómo normalizamos
incluso anhelamos el regreso a una
normalidad que ya nunca va a volver
porque no era normal la vida
prepandémica los niveles de consumo los
ritmos de la economía
los vuelos interoceánicos los niveles de
consumo de carne nada de eso puede
sostenerse dentro de los límites del
planeta entonces hoy estamos en una
distopía que es más un auto por una
profesión todo cumplida y que como los
procesos inflacionarios sabíamos que
esto iba a pasar le dimos rosca a todos
los elementos para que sucediera rápido
y hoy la estamos habitando precisamente
bueno sobre esto te quería preguntar un
poco nos estábamos adelantando flavia
recién pero ahora te lo pregunto más
concretamente no que enseñanzas y qué
cosas ha dejado expuesta la pandemia y
también su manejo por parte de los
gobiernos y también de organismos
bueno yo creo que ahí estuve también en
ese lugar muchas de las personas que
vimos los inicios del aislamiento como
una oportunidad reflexiva para tener
conversaciones profundas alrededor de
cómo surgió esta pandemia esta pandemia
surge indefectiblemente por una relación
abusiva y depredadora sobre las otras
formas de vida del planeta no sobre la
naturaleza y se sabe que de seguir
aumentando los modelos de
industrialización animal de
deforestación y de avances sobre
sistemas naturales cada vez más vamos a
estar en contacto con virus que han
mutado durante miles de años junto a
otras especies y que de repente se
encuentran con nuestros organismos
débiles y cosmopolitas en una
oportunidad enorme para estar más allá
de las teorías que existan sobre el
origen de la pandemia
del sars co2 como virus en sí mismo está
claro que es un virus que convivió con
otras especies durante mucho tiempo los
murciélagos pueden convivir con hasta 20
en su cuerpo t en simultáneo pero están
evolutivamente preparados para ello y
creíamos que el inicio de la pandemia
iba a ser una oportunidad para
reflexionar sobre esto sabemos que los
modelos de industrialización de animal a
gran escala producen nuevas pandemias ya
las vivimos anteriormente se dijo al
principio de esta la desaceleración
económica inicialmente redujo emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero abriendo
la oportunidad de ver si una nueva forma
de comunicarnos incluso globalmente era
posible pero rápidamente todas esas
esperanzas iniciales yo creo y veo
porque leyendo los patrones de cómo
están respondiendo los gobiernos a la
reactivación económica nada de nada
bueno está ocurriendo es decir todos los
planes de reactivación por más verdes
que se pinten los brindis los pactos
verdes están inyectando recursos a la
economía para salvar las mismas formas
de siempre subsidios a los combustibles
fósiles a la industria aeronáutica a la
industrialización animal entonces hoy la
realidad es que yo creo que la única
enseñanza positiva que ha dejado la
pandemia es eso que desde el activismo
reclamábamos un cambio radical rápido y
global y siempre nos dijeron que era
imposible dejó claro dejó claro la
pandemia porque si no ves que es posible
es posible hacerlo rápido y radicalmente
flavia profundice ha pasado rapidísimo
esta entrevista lamentablemente quisiera
continuar dialogando contigo pero bueno
llega a su fin y te agradezco muchísimo
su presencia en france 24 ha sido un
placer esta charla lo mismo digo muy
amable no gracias a vos y a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
con gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]
y